West African defense Chiefs meeting in
Nigeria to finalize a plan for a
possible intervention if negotiations
with niger's coup leaders remain
deadlocked
by our health hospital
to make sure that never again are we
going to allow uh the disruption of the
richest move towards Democratic
consolidation
cool leader Abdul rahmaniani says he
won't bow to pressure and is promising a
peaceful transition to democratic
elections he's warned any military
intervention will be met with Force
analysts say the economic community of
West African States or ecowas faces a
challenge
it's an uphill climb nothing easy about
it and we do have the risk of a regional
War here because we have Niger Mali and
Burkina possibly backed by Russia which
may be going up against 11 countries of
ecowats which nobody wants and that's
why all these calls for negotiations
Niger is one of the world's poorest
countries and relies heavily on
financial support from Western backers
and ecowas most of that Aid has been
frozen because of the coup prices for
basic goods are soaring there are also
rolling power Cuts after Nigeria cut
electricity supplies
frankly I felt it in my pocket and right
now where we are we're all stocking up
because in a month's time what's it
going to be like that's the question
even before the coup more than 3 million
of niger's 26 million population were
facing acute food shortages some Western
Nations have cut Aid to Niger worsening
the humanitarian situation in a country
where foreign aid makes up 40 of its
budget
Victoria Gayton B Al Jazeera